[Music]
it's amazing to meet you
it is simply extraordinary
maybe this will all make sense if I
explain Who I am my name is dr. Ellie
staple and I'm a psychiatrist my work
concerns a particular type of delusion
of grandeur it's a growing field I
specialize in those individuals who
believe they are superheroes good for
you the three of you have convinced
yourselves you have extraordinary gifts
like something out of a comic book David
Dunn the only person to survive that
trainwreck all those years ago
what do you do I'm in security you think
you have superpowers
it's a feeling vision I have to touch
them you believe you are a protector
my name is Patricia I have no question
there are two dozen identities I'm Mary
Reynolds senior we almost got servo that
live in that body with you to be coming
any minute now for you guys but what I
am questioning is your belief that you
are something more than human and yet it
is true my bones break easily and I've
had 94 breaks in my life but you have an
extraordinary thank you this is not a
cartoon this is the real world
no way and yet some of us still don't
die with bullets
some of us can still bend steel
I've been waiting for world to see that
be exist may I meet the beast I hope for
your sake that he likes you that sounds
like the bad guys
taming on a lot of people are going to
die
don't do this
are you ready
what do we call you sir first name mr.
last name
[Music]
[Music]
you